Rainbow six Xbox in close-quarters
battle and hostage-rescue assembled from
Special Forces teams around the world
the counterterrorism units these are the
elite German operators
this is kind of a shame
using the re DMK three Specter IQ was
able to scan and detect the signals of
any electronic devices nearby as she
says some gadgets are fun
some are deadly but still fun to destroy
Danno cavada wit his arm to the g52
tactical shield fitted with three rows
of mini flashbang grenades imagine
blinding the enemies with a lightning
strike so you can finish them off
Jagr specially designed magpie can
neutralize any incoming projectiles that
enter its field of vision aerospace
engineering and military training are
certainly a lethal combination
your skates it's a tune
and it can secure defenses by
electrifying barbed wire and reinforced
walls
any breach attempt will result in the
enemy's injury sometimes the old tricks
are the best ones for gsg-9 operators
self-reliance and ingenuity in the face
of danger are what make the through
bravely find it a fun